hello my name is greg gilliland i'm an
application scientist with agilent
technologies
and you have tuned into my discussion of
how the agilent 5800 5900 icp oes
systems make your epa 200.7 analysis
faster
easier
and more accurate than ever
let's dive in
the there's there's three ways basically
that uh that the 5800 5900 will make
your uh 200.7 uh
analysis faster easier and more accurate
so we're going to obviously start with
speed because that's the first thing on
our list
so
the
the speed
is enhanced by
a few things
first of all in telecom screening which
we will discuss
um svdv which is synchronous vertical
dual view
which i'll discuss
and the a avs six and seven uh switching
valve advanced valve system six and
seven which refers to the either six
port or seven port valve
so all of these will go into in this
little uh
in this
discussion um so intelliquat screening
this is our semi-quantitative screening
for um
for
across the periodic table basically uh
it costs about 10 seconds of sample when
you run it as part of a standard
analysis
you can actually do
though intelliquent screening it's about
20 seconds per sample and you can get
78 elements
a semi-quantitative look at 78 elements
in about 20 seconds
so this way you can look at your samples
you know what
wavelengths to avoid because of
interferences
you also know where to make your
standards in terms of concentrations you
don't have surprises in terms of samples
that would ordinarily blow you out of
the water
so you're actually able to plan a little
bit better
and see things coming down the road
instead of
getting that one sample that everybody
has had that uh you spend the rest of
the week cleaning your instrument out on
so
in addition uh to that you have uh a
number of nice little tools there's the
periodic table heat map which gives you
like i said semi-quantitative
concentrations across the periodic table
allows you to plan
your analysis accordingly
um
so moving on to svdb which is a
synchronous vertical dual
so synchronous vertical dual view is
basically the ability to
to look at both
radial and axial light
at the same time
from the same sample without having to
shift views without having to change the
optics somehow
without having to put a mirror into
their light path etc this
allows you to look axially and radially
at the same time um and since
simultaneous was sort of a compromised
term uh we decided to go with
synchronous um so synchronous vertical
dual view is is what that svdb stands
for and what that does is um
it's a
what makes that possible is a dichroic
spectral combiner which is a patented
um
optic that we have in the light path
that
acts as a window at the longer
wavelengths and acts as a mirror at the
shorter wavelengths so the ultimate
outgrowth of that is that the axial
wavelengths are reflected or the the
short wavelengths
are reflected and they they actually
comes from the axial view the longer
wavelengths are uh will will go past
through the window the dichroic spectral
combiner and uh will go to the detector
directly as you see in the diagram
so you can also run it in a traditional
way
you can run it axial only and in that
case in that
spot where you see the dichroic spectral
combiner there
you have a mirror
in that case there is no radial signal
whatsoever it's all axial the axial
bounces there it hits the mirror and
goes to the detector
there's also a way to run it
as strictly radial in that case you have
an open spot in that
particular optical spot and then that's
all
radial light
or you can run it the way traditional or
old-fashioned dual view systems run
which is to say they'll run all the
axial views and then they'll run all the
radials or vice versa
so that they split up it just takes
longer this is a this is a time saver
and generally speaking that time that it
takes to switch over to radial view
the time you're looking at the sample
for radial view all that time you can
save by doing
your samples via svdv
so um
like i said there it's about 20 seconds
faster than conventional um systems uh
when when you're running the standard
200.7 type analysis
so
the um
the next thing we're going to discuss
like i said was the avs six and seven
and uh as we as i mentioned abs
stands for advanced valve system six and
seven
the advanced valve system uh the heart
of that is the
the six or seven sample uh valve
that you see there
off to the right of your screen
um that is that is actually the sixth uh
the six port valve uh there um so the
seventh port is for internal standard
introduction um so that what this allows
is for you to fill a sample loop and a
lot of people are familiar with this
technique fill a sample loop um
and that sample loop is filled
with a high speed pump which you see on
the right
and then it slowly bled into the
nebulizer and then into the spray
chamber and plasma
while the front end of the system the
auto sampler probe etc is all rinsing
out
so you're essentially
removing all of the uptake time and all
of the rinse time from your analysis
so this is a gigantic time saver
it
generally speaking can shave off 60 to
90 seconds
in a typical analysis um
because generally you have
anywhere from 25 to 30 seconds of uptake
time
um
even at even at high pump speeds
and a certain
usually 20 seconds of stabilization time
and then you have 30
anywhere 30 to 60 seconds of rinse time
generally
depending on your system so you can save
a tremendous amount of time just with
the avs
so it is a it is a gigantic time saver
uh does have fully integrated hardware
and software uh there's nothing else
that you have to buy there's no software
discussion that has to take place or or
union it is part of the instrument and
the software is native to the to the
instrument software so there's nothing
else that you need to learn
um it does reduce the cost of analysis
by minimizing the time of analysis
obviously and the use of all the
resources that go into analysis
so that's another
another huge time saver and another
thing that makes your lab faster and and
more nimble
it is compatible with all auto samplers
no matter what auto sampler you're using
you can use
the avs six and seven
so you don't need your own special auto
sampler you don't need our
special auto sampler
so
so that pretty much puts to bed the the
speed uh portion of of the discussion
the uh
the the the three ways that i i said we
would we would make your analysis faster
um
now in terms of ease of use
um
making your life easier intellectual 2.0
this is another facet of intelliquant
that i wanted to discuss along with emmf
and ocf
and we at agilent are very very proud of
our three-letter acronyms so i thought
i'd throw some in for you but i will
tell you what they mean
um
so intelliquat 2.0
is just the second generation of
intelliquant um those of you familiar
with our
uh 5100 and 5110 icp oes systems
um from a few years back uh will
remember
initially in telequan it's a terrific
idea it's a semi-quantitative look at
basically the whole periodic table
and teleport 2.0 takes that
and and kind of takes it to the next
level
by
by actually
giving you a star rating system
when it looks at wavelengths you can
scan your your samples
it'll tell you what's in your samples
and it'll tell you what wavelengths it
thinks you should use to analyze your
samples and which ones it thinks you
shouldn't use
so in this case you've got a star rating
system from one to five stars for all of
these uh emission lines um and then
some of them have a question mark and
those question marks indicate problems
with those specific emission lines uh in
this case you see this boron line is
flagged for uh
having very poor confidence and it's got
a big iron interference so they don't
they they recommend that you don't use
it
and in fact they tell you which one they
they do recommend with the green check
mark
so
it's it's like having a spectroscopist
who's got years of of uh
of uh experience and insight
right there with you doing your method
development
and i realized that 200.7 there's not a
lot of method development that goes in
but there's some
i've set up 2.7 methods at many many
commercial environmental labs
and there's always some level of method
development that goes into this and this
would tend to make it a little bit
easier
granted you don't know what samples are
going to come in the door
but this will certainly
make things
easier when you're developing methods
and when you're running a new sample
type that comes in the door
so um in addition to that the this
simplified list of uh
of wavelengths the ones that actually do
have green check marks and were used uh
by intelliquant uh can be copied and
pasted into a new uh worksheet where you
can just take this information directly
make a new worksheet and that is your
those are your your analyte wavelength
for
per analysis
so
there's intel
2.0 let's go to emf
um
emf uh love the x
acronyms stands for early maintenance
feedback
um early maintenance feedback is really
a customizable maintenance
schedule
uh for your system
you're able to
dial all these
schedules up based on your
specific experience running the
instrument based on your experience with
your samples because nobody knows your
samples better than you
it allows you to
create new maintenance items it allows
you to
customize the existing maintenance items
you can actually have optional pop-up
alerts
that will actually pop up in the middle
of your analysis and tell you that
something needs to be addressed
look at the axial viewing window change
the tubing
clean the nebulizer clean the torch etc
etc
all those things
are able to be turned into a pop-up that
will at least give the analyst cause to
either dismiss or reset those uh those
items um at the instrument
so um in addition uh you can actually
time the uh
the life cycle of each of these items by
the the number of hours the instruments
actually on the number of plasma hours
you run uh the number of samples or just
the sheer number of days
since the last maintenance item has gone
through so uh pretty flexible
and really really handy
especially when you have a lot of users
using an instrument
i think it's extremely handy to have
something like this
in your corner
so uh ocf
uh yet another three-letter
acronym
which stands for
layer conditional formatting
outlier conditional formatting is a
is a feature that allows you to actually
have
track 6
qc parameters uh and to track when you
see the failures of this these qc
parameters they're they're customizable
um you know in the case of like
your result concentration percent rsd
you can have it flagged if your percent
rsv for for a result is over five
percent
but when you get to very low values
all your rfds are over five percent
because they're very low and there's a
lot of noise associated with them so you
can actually have that apply only when
it's three times the mdl or some other
multiple times the mdl
so
these are
kind of scalable to what you want to do
with them
but they uh they pop up with nice
colored flags on your data so that you
can see where the failures happen
um and in the case where you have just a
gigantic amount of data which you which
i frequently do um and you want to be
able to find those failures
it's handy to actually click there's a
there's a show only failures button and
it will just show you the qc uh that
failed
then you're able to dial in and figure
out what's going on with those specific
samples for those specific analytes
which is a little bit easier than trying
to find a needle in a haystack looking
at you know
10 different wavelengths for everything
which is kind of what i do a lot of the
time so
it makes it makes it very simple
um
so those are the the three ease of use
items i wanted to go over intelliquat
2.0
and the ability to uh
to
have the instrument select wavelength
for you
um emf
um so that early maintenance uh
so that you don't do maintenance more
frequently than you need to but you get
the maintenance done in a timely fashion
and it lets you know when the
maintenance is due
and ocf outlier conditional formatting
where you're actually able to
set up your
your flags so that they intelligently
flag your samples and
you're actually able to winnow through
all the data and just find the failures
so that you can address them
and rerun
analysis if need be
so moving on to the accuracy part of the
equation
um
the
the accuracy part as you may have
guessed from my previous slides will
probably have three parts
improved resolution um improve detection
limits and improve stability
so um
i was very impressed first of all with
with our past generations of icp oes
i've been doing icp for upwards of 30
years
and the these these last two generations
the 5100 and the 5110 i thought were
just amazing instruments and i was
absolutely tickled with the performance
and so when when the engineers came um
and talked to us about this new
generation of systems and they said well
the optics are going to be smaller i
thought
oh what did we give up what what what's
going to happen
what
why would we do this um and so uh when
when they presented
this to us they they started talking
about uh
signal density and and things like that
they showed some diagrams of taken from
the the 5110 our previous generation of
systems um this happens to be the
arsenal arsenic at 188
um so you see the peak and you see the
signal density in the on the
two-dimensional array because everything
takes place on the on the
two-dimensional uh chip
so you can see the uh the photon density
there um this is without free-form
optics
now they added a free-form collimating
mirror to the system and this is what it
did
to the signal density
um
and
it it's amazing the the difference
between
this signal density and this uh
the slope of the spectra is incredible
so much more density so much better
defined the peak is so much better
defined
so the resolution has improved radically
the detection limits have improved
radically just because of this one
single optical component
what is this optical component you ask
well let me just quickly show you
this is a diagram or kind of a mock-up
of our
our optics
the optical tank
the torch would be sitting down here in
the
lower right
as you look at it
so what we see here in the lower left is
the detector
so you can see the ray tracing back to
the
the focusing mirror
back through the the uh prism and the
grating there at the lower center
and then there's the freeform
collimating mirror up in the upper right
bringing it down to the the pre-optics
and the
uh entrance slit
in the lower left
yes
um so
the freeform collimating mirror
what is a freeform
freeform optics
are
not
traditionally surfaced optics they're uh
in fact on a on a nano scale they look
kind of like a pringle and in fact some
people like to call this the pringle um
it looks like a pringled potato chip um
it's not really truly that radical when
you look at it because that is on a
grossly exaggerated scale
but
what this does is eliminates aberrations
in the optical image
because as you know in a in a
spectrometer what you're trying to do is
take light which actually focuses in a
uh
it doesn't it there's there's no flat
focus fields in a in a traditional
optical system
so because there's no flat focus you
have to correct for those
those aberrations that take place on the
edge
of the field of focus and that's what
what a freeform optic does
so not only did we put this in the
spectrometer but we actually came up
with a better way to manufacture and
replicate these free form optics
so that is uh
is really the big idea behind the 5800
5900
it allowed us to shrink the optics uh
box actually
by i believe
i i think somewhat something around half
about 50 smaller the optics box is
honestly
about
i don't know about two feet
maybe a little bit more um
and that's it that's that's how that's
how big the optics
box is it's very small
and so of course the added benefit is
that it purges very quickly uh and it's
easy to maintain uh
the temperature it gets up to
temperature quickly because it is
thermostatic so there's a lot of
benefits to having the smaller optics um
it's
but the the performance is is where it's
at so what does all this
uh
hand wavy updates get us
um
and hopefully this doesn't get in the
way in my life it doesn't um so the
the detection limits that we're seeing
um
for some of the kind of common toxic
elements um arsenic at 1.1 cadmium is
always great uh mercury at 0.3 ppb lead
at 1.1 thallium at 1.1 the percent
reduction from the previous detection
limits which were not shabby
is amazing 70 percent for our sync 70
reduction in the detection limit so
this has made a tremendous difference
in
in the numbers that you're going to get
for your low level
uh metals especially the difficult
metals
that you see in environmental analysis
and in the reliability of the data
especially down low uh when you're
having to run your uh run at your at
your cri or or at the uh at the very
very low level at reporting limit uh
this makes those numbers much more
reliable um granted it's going to push
reporting limits down probably um
but
but that's the business we're all in
right
the instrument can do something cool and
new and people start taking advantage of
it and then we all have to live up to
that for the next 10 years until it all
pushes down again
by a factor of 10. so
at any rate um the
the detection limits and the resolution
with this system are incredible and the
uh performance that you see in a
standard 200.7 run
um
is remarkable compared to even compared
to the older system which i thought was
very very good um
it is
it's outstanding
so
um this resolution
piece of the puzzle i would say that's
done done the stability
is
impeccable so you get all the benefits
that you had with the previous system to
begin with
and you have the
greatly enhanced performance
that that
that free form optic is giving you
so the speed the ease of use the
accuracy
all come together
but i'm sure you knew that there had to
be some more so there is going to be an
etc piece of the puzzle
and uh the etc
um comes in the form of a few
other things that
uh didn't get mentioned along the way
but i will throw those out um just as a
kind of an aside um so that you're aware
so we talked about outlier conditional
formatting
we talked about early maintenance
feedback
let's talk about neb alert
and some other things as well
but what all these kind of come together
to form is something we call smart tools
and smart tools will uh help you gain
insight into your instrument operation
um
and reduce re-measurement that's the
whole idea these things um
it's information that we can provide to
you on the instrument and how it's
operating so that you can take
corrective action and keep your
instrument
up and running properly so that you
don't have to go back and rerun stuff
because nobody's making any money if
they're having to rerun stuff
and
and nobody's having any fun if they're
having to rerun stuff so at the bench
it's no fun because i've been there and
in the front office and the corner
office it's no fun because you're not
making money so these things are
important to everybody at any position
in the laboratory
um
so let's talk about things like the like
neb alert um
alert is
a uh
it's a monitor it monitors the back
pressure of your nebulizer so it can
actually tell
um if the
if your back pressure suddenly spikes up
it's pretty sure that there's a blockage
in your nebulizer it will alert you of
that and you can set it up so that it
actually gives you
a pop-up
on your screen that says hey we think
your nebulizer's blocked
it will also
in the same vein as it's monitoring your
back pressure if that back pressure
crashes and there's just no back
pressure anymore then it assumes that
the nebulizers come on uh come
unconnected or something to that effect
and it will give you a pop-up message as
well so
rather than running
all day or all night with uh
with a nebulizer that's uh
that's crashed on you um and wasting all
that sample all those resources um
which is soul killing i know because
i've been there this will allow you to
stop it it'll stop your run and you can
go back and and take care of things
uh clean up your nebulizer replace the
nebulizer and start over what have you
stuff you wouldn't know until maybe you
uh
maybe you came in in the morning or
somebody else happened to look at or go
over and look at the data
this actually gives you a pop-up message
that indicates that there's a problem
so i think that's really cool
as
someone who's who's done this um
intelligent rinse is uh is something
that we added in this version of
software
um now this isn't something where
it rinses different times
it will only rinse a maximum amount in
this case it'll ask you what your max
rinse time is in we set it at 60 seconds
but that's the most it will ever rinse
but what it will do is monitor the lines
that you specify at the levels that you
specify and if
it returns to the same stable baseline
that it determined before the analysis
then it will stop rinsing
for instance if you're running brine
samples and it returns back to
the previously determined stable
baseline
for sodium
it will keep going um
and if it hasn't it will rinse the
maximum amount and then it will tell you
if it has if it still hasn't reached the
baseline for for certain wavelengths
this is really handy because you don't
want to use more rinse than you need but
it's if you're running some especially
unknown samples you have no idea what
they are or if you really if you know
they're nasty
maybe you do want to put in some some
really long rinses but say when you're
coming off of the blank or you're coming
off of some
uh meth your prep blank etc you don't
need to run those awfully long rinses so
you can save some some time and save
some rinse solution by not running fast
pump for 90 seconds or what have you um
and and just back that down to only when
you need it
i like this feature it's uh it's very
useful and it um it keeps things more
efficient in the lab
so
um there's also the internal standard
monitor
um that we introduced it's not this
version but it's it was a couple
versions ago
those of you who are familiar with our
icpms products
will probably be familiar with the way
this looks it just tracks the internal
standards
you can see if you have an internal
standard crash out you can see what the
trends are in this case it's pretty uh
pretty mellow i think that's all
plus or minus 10 if i'm reading the
scale correctly with my poor eyesight
but at any rate this is this is a a
handy tool um and you can actually it
actually identifies what the uh
what the uh
standards are there so you can see which
ones are good which ones are not if so
uh and act
accordingly um
in addition to that
well
there's a couple of other features
we won't go back on that we'll just stay
where we are
so in addition to those smart tools
there are a set of smart tools that give
you insights into your into your samples
we've already talked about intelliquat
screening uh we've talked about
spectral identi spectral interference
identification um and uh
you know waste
the way that intelliquat helps you
understand your samples composition um a
couple other things uh to mention uh the
in intellipoint also helps you identify
what kind of sample prep problems may
have taken place um the nice thing i've
seen in intelliquat is
um
you get a chlorine number say for
instance there's
uh hcl uh hydrochloric used in your in
your sample prep or they're supposed to
be
if you don't see chlorine then you don't
have hcl in your samples and that maybe
there's a prep problem that you can
identify immediately
conversely maybe someone did use hcl and
they weren't supposed to
you can identify that as well and you
can nip that in the bud and get your
samples prepped properly
so you don't go through the whole prep
process or the whole prep process and
the analysis process and then realize
that they were prepped incorrectly
so there is that
there is also the
argon emission monitor which i find
pretty useful it really just tracks the
emission of
a certain suite of argon lines
and allows you to look at them for each
sample that you ran
so this sort of allows you to track the
plasma efficiency
how hot the plasma was
whether or not there was any issue with
sample interruption sample flow
interruption
or anything like that along the way
or if there was some sort of massive uh
suppression because of sample matrix you
can certainly see the
arsenic
emission
hit the floor
occasionally it will do that as well so
there are
uh ways to uh
there this is a very useful technique to
be able to use uh things like that um
so
moving on from
ways we can
help you make your analysis faster
easier and more accurate
there's sort of what's coming up on the
horizon for environmental
environmental topics
the epa is working actively on ucmr5
and that is
a list of emerging contaminants um that
are likely to be added to
permits in the in the future they're at
least going to be studied um and so that
process is going on right now
uh i think it was a little bit delayed
by uh the covid19 uh issue in 2020
uh
it was a great year wasn't it um
so at this point
it's actually uh in pre-publication
um it's under review uh as of the 20th
of uh last month um once it's published
the epa will host a couple of
identical webinars
and they'll discuss the lab approval
process for this
for the for the pilot study
um
laboratory methods and monitoring
requirements um so all this will be
discussed so this whole process is uh
is kind of
um
well it's something that the epa goes
through about every five years
where they add contaminants in this case
a lot of the contaminants that are being
added are pfas
uh they've been a lot in the news those
uh these these plastics that just don't
go away in our environment um but the
one that they've added for
uh of interest to 200.7 and then those
two run 200.7 is lithium um so if you
have not
or are not looking at lithium uh might
be a good idea to start including that
into your uh into your program um it's
something that is going to be coming up
before long uh and if your laboratory
would like to get on the cutting edge
and uh and maybe help the epa collect
some data then that is certainly
something you can do
uh
there's a whole landing page for ucmr5
uh at epa.gov
you can get involved and you can apply
to be part of the
of the pro proficiency uh
monitoring process so um
i think that's all that i had for now uh
thank you very much for your attention i
appreciate it and uh i look forward to
talking to you again next time
and uh thank you for your participation
and i will be around for questions
during the live virtual environmental
summit thank you
bye